I do have 102 deleted scenes and and  especially one that I was a little bit  kind of a little bit sad about losing it  didn't affect the scoring in a big way  but it was one way young author you know  on a deer with a crippled feet school  getfriends goes swimming down into like  a ship wreckage and he ends up getting  stuck in there and and basically he  drowns and that's when he because finds  out that he has the ability to brief on  the water so it's a really cool scene  it's a great moment and I think it would  help you know feeling any guess if  people have for the water it has that  and it has a limit of it and then that  scene answer because encounter with  seeing Volkow for the first time  Williams character movie was getting a  bit too long for me and I did find stuff  to cut  [Music]